caitlyn i know last week was a tough
week
it felt like at moments you gave up
because you had a moment of chaos there
and i felt like your spirit dropped
this wasn't another it was another not
great dance of yours
can you do a back tuck on your own no
okay
so i'm going to call that a lift okay
it's not a jump that she can do on her
own it starts being real personal
it does artem chick vincent
and caitlyn bristow aren't feeling the
feedback they've been getting from
long time dancing with the stars judge
carrie ann anaba
i think there's definitely saying that
maybe not a different standard but it's
definitely i feel like different
expectations
e.t caught up with the dancing pro and
the former bachelorette on monday night
after their jive and relay performances
which by the way received mostly
positive comments from the other judges
derek huff and bruno tonioli you always
have
so much content in your dances the kicks
the potter rays
the sugar pushes honestly you have
what it takes you can do everything but
carry anne
not so much
it's not a jump that she can do on her
own she lifted her through the tuck
sorry i'm going to keep fighting for it
okay
all right here i am's fighting how are
you feeling right now
i i'm not going to fight back because i
respect all the judges
yeah and last week she said this
it felt like at moments you gave up like
there was moments and i felt like
because you had a moment of chaos there
and i saw it in your eyes and i felt
like your spirit dropped
you know what at this point it starts
being a little personal i feel like yes
i think there's definitely saying that
maybe not a different standard but it's
definitely like a different expectations
i feel i don't know like i'm watching
back the dance itself right
and when it comes to like well you could
kick sharper well i can say about
everybody who danced on the show today
they put down something better
you know what i mean like i i could like
i'm not
i don't know it's it's really odd and
caitlyn who hosts her own podcast called
off the vine is just as stumped as artem
i would love to like have her on the
podcast
ask her a few questions i don't know
i don't know and it's it's always
reassuring to
talk to other people and have them
asking those same questions because we
come back and we're like
huh and like and we're good at accepting
constructive criticism we'll be like
okay great now let's apply it that's
wonderful thank you for the feedback
and with this one it's like huh okay
the 35 year old added that she's mostly
just confused by carrie anne's
intentions
i just want to know like where it comes
from is it from a place where you
believe in us
and you want us to do better is it
coming from a place
of like oh but i was hard on hannah and
you're another bachelor
girl is it coming from a place where is
it coming from and
how are we supposed to take it and
bring it into our next rehearsal what do
you want us to channel and use from it
it's very hard to understand that
derek says things and i'm like great
oh my gosh i could work on that and
let's use that next time
same with bruno and then when carrie
says things i'm like
what do you want us to do with that
as for artem he just doesn't want carrie
anne's comments to affect the energy
caitlyn brings to her performances
each week like at this point right now
we just feel like we're just
never to make it happen you know what i
mean
that's how it feels it feels really
discouraging in the sense to come back
next week because oh
like i almost literally want to have an
ear mask and put on top of the head and
after last week's episode when carrie
anne told caitlyn it looked like
she gave up yeah artem wasn't there for
that note either
if it's a constructed criticism please
go ahead like i'm all up for it but
giving up and feeling like i just didn't
feel
i just didn't feel it like that's not a
constructive criticism
yeah we're judging dancing we're not
judging how we feel about it
yeah that's not in my character to give
up
if anything i'm tired at one point but i
am pushing through as
hard as i possibly can i would never
give up
carrie anne lenscrafters called your
prescriptions
[Laughter]
[Music]
in